The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OK, so.
Pretty full day again.
I had last time introduced
the Fourier matrix,
the discrete Fourier transform.
Well, more strictly, the
discrete Fourier transform
is usually this one.
It takes the function values
and produces the coefficients.
And then I started with the
coefficients, added back,
added up the series to
get the function values.
So F or F inverse.
So we didn't do examples yet.
And one natural example is the
discrete delta function that
has a one in the zero position.
That's easy to do.
And then we should
do also a shift,
to see what's the effect, if
you shift the function, what
happens to the transform.
That's an important rule,
important for Fourier series
and Fourier integrals, too.
Because often you do that, and
it's going to be a simple rule.
If you shift the function, the
transform does something nice.
OK, and then I want to
describe a little about the FFT
and then start on the next
section, convolutions.
So that's fun and
that's a big deal.
OK, about reviews, I'll
be here as usual today.
I think maybe the 26th, just
hours before Thanksgiving,
we can give ourselves a holiday.
So not next Wednesday but
then certainly the Wednesday
of the following week would
be a sort of major quiz
review in the review session.
And in class.
OK, ready to go?
On this example
gives us a chance
just to remember what the matrix
looks like, because we're just
going to, if I multiply this
inverse matrix by that vector
it's just going to pick
off the first column
and it'll be totally
easy so let's just do it.
So if y is this one, I
want to know about f.
What are the
Fourier coefficients
of the delta function?
Discrete delta function?
OK, before I even do it,
we got a pretty good idea
what to expect.
Because we remember what
happened to the ordinary delta
function, in continuous time.
Or rather, I guess it was
the periodic delta function.
Do you remember
the coefficients,
what were the coefficients for
the periodic delta function?
You remember those?
We took the integral
from minus pi
to pi of our function,
which was delta(x).
And then we had to
remember to divide by 2pi,
and you remember the
coefficients are e^(-ikx).
This is c_k in the periodic
case, the 2pi periodic case.
The function is
the delta function,
and you remember that if we
want coefficient k we multiply
by e^(-ikx).
That's the thing that will
pick out the e^(+ikx) term.
And of course everybody knows
what we get here, this delta,
this spike at x=0, means we
take the value of that function
at zero, which is one,
so we just get 1/(2pi).
For all the Fourier coefficients
of the delta function.
The point being that
they're all the same.
That all frequencies are
in the delta function
to the same amount.
I mean that's kind of nice.
We created the delta
function for other reasons,
but then here in Fourier space
it's just clean as could be.
And we'll expect
something here, too.
You remember what F inverse is?
F inverse is 1/N, instead
of 1/2pi, and then
the entries of F inverse come
from F bar, the conjugate.
So it's just one, one,
one, minus-- Well,
I've made it four by four here.
This is minus omega--
No, it isn't minus omega.
It's it's omega bar, which
is minus i, in this case.
Omega bar, so it's minus
i, that's omega bar.
And the next one would be
omega bar squared, and cubed,
and so on.
All the way up to
the ninth power.
But we're multiplying
by one, zero, zero,
so none of that matters.
What's the answer?
I'm doing this discrete
Fourier transform,
so I'm multiplying by the matrix
with the complex conjugate
guys.
But I'm multiplying
by that simple thing
so it's just going to pick
out the zeroth column.
In other words, constant.
All the discrete
Fourier coefficients
of the discrete
delta are the same.
Just again.
And what are they?
So it picks out this
column, but of course it
divides by N, so the answer
was 1/N [1, 1, 1, 1].
It's just constant with the 1/N,
where in the continuous case we
had 1/(2pi).
No problem.
OK.
And, of course, everybody
knows, suppose that I now
start with these
coefficients and add back
to get the function.
What would I get?
Because, just to be sure
that we believe that F and F
inverse really are what
they are supposed to be.
If I start with
these coefficients,
add back to put those in here
and reconstruct, so 1/N [ 1, 1,
1], what will I get?
Well, what am I supposed to get?
The delta, right?
I'm supposed to get back to y.
If I started with
that, did F inverse
to get the coefficients,
that was the discrete Fourier
transform, now I add back to
get, add the Fourier series up
again to come back
here, well I'll
certainly get [1, 0, 0, 0],
and you see why?
If I multiply F, that zeroth
row of F is [1, 1, 1, 1],
times [1, 1, 1, 1] will give
me N. The N will cancel.
I get the one.
And all the other
guys add to zeroes.
So, sure enough, it works.
We're really just seeing an
example, an important example
of the DFT.
And the homework, then, would
have some other examples.
But I've forgotten whether
the homework has this example.
But let's think about it now.
Suppose that's my
function value instead.
OK, so now I'm starting
with the delta.
Again it's a delta,
but it's moved over.
And I could ask, I
really should ask
first, in the continuous
case, suppose I,
I can do it with just
a little erasing here.
Let me do the continuous
case for the delta
that we met first
in this course.
I'll shift it to a.
If I shift the delta
function to a point a,
well, I said we'd met the delta
function first in this course.
At a, good.
But when we did it
wasn't 2pi periodic.
So we still have, in fact, the
Fourier integrals next week.
Will have a similar formula.
The integral will go from
minus infinity to infinity
and then we'll have the
real delta, not periodic.
Here, we have, and people
call it a train of deltas.
A train of spikes.
Sort of you have one every 2pi.
Anyway, that's what we've got.
Now, you can see the answer.
This is like perfect practice in
doing an integral with a delta.
What's the integral equal?
Well, the spike is at x=a.
So it picks out this function
at x=a, which is e^(-ika).
So not constant any more.
They depend on k.
The 1/(2pi) is still there.
So it's-- But still, the
delta function shifted over.
I mean, it didn't change energy.
It didn't change, it just
changed phase, so to speak.
And we see that-- I would
call this like a modulation.
So it's staying of
absolute value one, still.
But it's not the number one,
it's going around the circle.
Going around the unit circle.
So it's a phase factor, right.
And that's what I'm going
to expect to see here
in the discrete case too.
If I do this multiplication
by one there,
it picks out this column, right?
That one will pick
out this column,
so you see it's-- Maybe
I come up here now.
Shall I just-- When I
pick out that column,
the answer then, I guess
I've got the column circle,
there it is.
Minus i, minus i
squared, minus i cubed.
You see it's like k equals
zero, one, two, three.
Just the way here,
we had k, well we
had all integers k in
that function case.
Here we've got four
integers, k equals zero, one,
two, and three, but again it's
the minus i, it's the e to the,
it's the w bar.
In other words, the answer
was one, w bar, w bar squared,
w bar cubed.
Just the powers of
w with this factor
1/N. Here we had a modulation.
It's the same picture.
Absolute value's one.
And and what about energy?
Having mentioned energy,
so that's another key rule.
The key rules for the Fourier
series, just let's think back.
What were the key rules?
First, the rule to
find the coefficients.
Good.
Then the rule for
the derivatives.
This is so important.
These are rules.
Let's say, for Fourier series.
For Fourier series.
Let's just make
this a quick review.
What were the important rules?
The important rules were, if
I had the Fourier series of f.
Start with the
Fourier series of f.
Then the question was, what's
the Fourier series of df/dx.
And now I'm saying the
next important rule
is the Fourier
series of f shifted.
And then the last important
rule is the energy.
OK, and let's just,
maybe this is a bad idea
to, since we're kind of
doing all of Fourier in,
it's coming in three parts.
Functions, discrete,
integrals, but they all match.
So this is what happens
to the function.
What happens to the coefficient?
So this starts with
coefficient c_k,
for f, what are the
coefficients for the derivative,
just remind me?
If f(x), so I'm starting with
f(x) equals sum of c_k*e^(ikx).
Start with that.
And now take the derivative.
When I take the
derivative, down comes ik.
So you remember that rule.
Those are the Fourier
coefficients of the derivative.
Now what's the Fourier
coefficients of the shift?
If I've just shifted,
translated the function,
if my original x was this,
now let me look at f(x-a).
You'll see it.
It'll jump out at us,
it'll be a sum of the same
c_k's e^(ik(x-a)).
So what are the Fourier
coefficients of that?
Well there is the e^(ikx).
Whatever's multiplying it
has got to be the Fourier
coefficient, and we see it
is c_k times e^(ik(-a)).
e^(-ika) times c_k.
Right?
And, of course, that's just
what we discovered here.
That's just what we found there,
that when we shifted the delta,
we've multiplied
by this modulation,
this phase factor came into
the Fourier coefficients.
And now finally,
the energy stuff.
You remember the energy
was, what's the energy?
The integral from
minus pi to pi, of f(x)
squared dx is the same as
the sum from minus infinity
to infinity of the
coefficient squared.
And somebody correctly
sent me an email
to say energy and length
squared are you really,
is there much difference?
No.
You could say
length squared here,
I'm just using the word energy.
Now, I left a space
because I know that there's
a stupid 2pi somewhere.
Where does it come?
You remember how to get this?
You put that whole
series in there,
multiply by its complex
conjugate to get squared.
And integrate.
Right?
That was the idea.
Isn't that how we figured
out, we got to this?
We started with
this, length squared.
We plugged in the
Fourier series.
This is f times f bar, so
that's this times its conjugate.
And we integrated, and all
the cross terms vanished.
And only the ones where e^(ikx)
multiplied e^(-ikx) came.
And those had c_k squared.
And when we integrated that
one, we probably got a 2pi.
So that's the energy
inequality, right.
For functions.
And now what I was
going to say is,
you shouldn't miss the fact
that in the discrete case,
there'll be a similar
energy inequality.
So we had y was the
Fourier matrix times c.
Now, if I take the
length squared of both,
y, so I'm going to-- Right?
That's the same as that.
Now I'm going to do
the same as this.
I'm going to find
the length squared,
which will be y transpose y.
No, it won't be y transpose y.
What is length squared?
y bar transpose y.
I have to do that right.
That will be, substituting,
that's c bar F
bar transpose times y is Fc.
Just plugged it in,
and now what do I use?
The key fact, the fact that
the columns are orthogonal.
That's what made all these
integrals simple, right?
When I put that into there,
a whole lot of integrals
had to be zero.
When I put this in, a
whole lot of dot products
have to be zero.
Rows of F bar times
columns of F, all zero,
except when I'm
hitting the same row.
And when I'm hitting that
same row I get an N. So I get,
this is N c bar transpose c.
And that's c squared.
That's the energy inequality,
it's just orthogonality
once again.
Everything in these weeks is
coming out of orthogonality.
Orthogonality is the fact that
this is N times the identity.
Right?
Well, OK that's a
quick recall of a bunch
of stuff for functions.
And just seeing maybe
for the first time
the discrete analogs.
I guess I don't have a brilliant
idea for the discrete analog
of the derivative.
Well, guess there's
a natural idea,
it would be a finite
difference, but somehow that
isn't a rule that
gets like, high marks.
But we saw the discrete
analog of the shift
and now we see the
energy inequality
is just that the length
of the function squared
is equal to N times the length
of the coefficients squared.
OK with that?
Lots of formulas here.
Let's see.
Do some examples.
I mean, these were
simple examples.
And I think the homework
gives you some more.
You should be able to take
the Fourier transform and go
backwards.
And when we do convolution
in a few minutes,
we're certainly going to
be taking the Fourier,
we're going to be
going both ways.
And use all these facts.
OK, I'll pause a moment.
That's topic one.
Topic two, fast
Fourier transform.
Wow.
What's the good way to--
I mean, any decent machine
comes with the FFT hardwired in.
So you might say,
OK I'll just use it.
And that seems totally
reasonable to me.
But you might like to see
just on one board, what's
the key idea?
What's the little bit of
algebra that makes it work?
So I'll just have one
board here for the FFT
and a little bit of algebra.
Simple, simple but
once it hit the world,
well, computer scientists
just love the recursion
that comes in there.
So they look for that in every
possible other algorithm now.
OK, let me see that point.
So here's the main point.
That if I want to take the--
multiply by F of size 1,024,
the fast Fourier transform
connects that full matrix
to a half-full matrix.
It connects that to
the half-full matrix
that takes the half-size
transforms separately.
So it's half-full
because of these zeroes.
That's the point.
That the 1,024 matrix is
connected to the 512 matrix.
And what's underlying that?
The 1,024 matrix is full of e
to the 2pi*i, the w, over 1,024,
right?
That's the w for this guy.
And then the w for this
guy, for both of these,
is e^(2pi*i/512).
So if there's a connection
between that matrix
and this matrix,
there'd better be
a connection between that
number and that number.
Because this is the number
that fills this one,
and this is the number
that fills these.
So what's the connection?
It's just perfect, right?
If I take this number, which is
one part of the whole circle,
1/1,024, a fraction
of the whole circle,
what do I do to get this guy?
To get one 512th of the
way around the circle?
I square it.
The square of this w is this w.
Let me call this w_N,
and this one w_M.
Maybe I'll use caps, yeah I'm
using cap N, this is my w.
This is the one I want.
The w_N, the N by
N one, N is 1,024,
and the point is, everybody
saw that, when I squared it
I doubled the angle?
When I doubled that angle the
two over that gave me 1/512.
Fantastic.
Of course, that doesn't
make this equal to that,
but it suggests that there
is a close connection.
So let me finish here the
key idea of the Fourier
transform in block matrix form.
What's the key idea?
So instead of doing the big
transform, the full size,
I'm going to do two half-sizes.
But what am I going
to apply those to?
Here's the trick.
These two separate guys apply to
the odd-numbered coefficients.
The odd-numbered component.
And the even.
So I have to first do
a little permutation,
and even comes first, always.
Even means zero, two,
four, up to a 1,022.
So this is zero, two;
zero up to 1,022.
And then come all the odd guys.
One up to 1,023.
So this is a permutation,
a simple permutation.
Just take your 1,024 numbers,
pick out the even ones,
put them on top.
Right?
In other words, put
them on top where
512 is going to act on it.
Put the odd ones at the
bottom, the last 512,
that guy will act on that.
So there's 512 numbers there,
with the even coefficients,
this acts.
OK, now we've got two
half-size transforms.
Because we're applying this
to the y, to a to a typical y.
OK.
But I've just
written F without a y
so I don't really need a y here.
This is a matrix identity.
It's a matrix identity that's
got a bunch of zeroes there.
Of course, that matrix
is full of zeroes.
I mean, this is instant
speed to do that permutation.
Grab the evens, put them
in front of the odds.
OK, so now I've
got two half-sizes,
but then I have to
put them back together
to get the full-size matrix.
And that is also a matrix.
Turns out to be
a diagonal there,
and a minus the
diagonal goes there.
So actually, that
looks great too, right?
Full of zeroes, the identity.
No multiplications whatever.
Well, these are the
only multiplications,
sometimes they're called twiddle
factors, give it a fancy name.
Official sounding
name, twiddle factors.
OK, so that diagonal
matrix D, what's that?
That diagonal matrix D happens
to be just the powers of w,
sit along D. 1,
w, up to w to the,
this is w_N, we're
talking, the big w,
and it's only half-size
so it goes up to M-1.
Half, M is half of N.
Everybody's got that, right?
M is half of N here.
I'll get that
written on the board.
M is 512, N is 1,024,
here we have the powers
of this guy up to 511.
The total size being 512 because
that's a 512 by 512 matrix.
I guess I can
remember somewhere,
being at a conference,
this was probably soon
after the FFT became
sort of famous.
And then somebody who was
just presenting the idea
and as soon as it was presented
that way, I was happy.
I guess.
I thought OK, there
you see the idea.
Permutation, reorder
the even-odd.
Two half-size transforms,
put them back together.
And what's happened here?
The work of this
matrix, multiplying
by this matrix, which
would be 1,024 squared
is now practically cut in half.
Because this is nothing.
And we have just this
diagonal multiplication to do,
and of course this is the same
as that, just with minus signs.
So the total multiplications
we have to do,
the total number of twiddle
factors, is just 512,
and then we're golden.
So we've got half the work
plus 512, 512 operations.
That's pretty good.
And of course it gets better.
How?
Once you have the idea
of getting down to 512,
what are you going to do now?
This is the computer
scientist's favorite idea.
Do it again.
That's what it comes to.
Whatever worked for 1,024 to
get to 512 is going to work.
So now I'll split this
up into, well, each 512,
so now I have to do, yeah.
Let me write F_512 will
be, it's now smaller.
An I, an I, and a D and a
minus D for the 512 size,
of F_256, 256 and
then the permutation,
the odd-even
permutation P. So we're
doing this idea in
there, and in there.
So it's just recursive.
Recursive.
And now, if we go
all the way, so you
see why I keep
taking powers of two.
It's natural to
have powers of two.
Two or three.
Three is also good.
I mean, all this
gets so optimized
that powers of two or
three are pretty good.
And you just use the same idea.
There'd be a similar idea here
for, if I was doing instead
of odd-even, even-odd I was
doing maybe three groups.
But stick with two, that's fine.
Then you might ask,
if you were a worrier
I guess you might ask what
if it's not a power of two.
I think you just add in zeroes.
Just pad it out to be
the next power of two.
Nothing difficult there.
I think that's right.
Hope that's right.
And once this idea came out, of
course, people started looking.
What if the number
here was prime?
And found another
neat bit of algebra
that worked OK
for prime numbers.
Using a little bit
of number theory.
But the ultimate
winner was this one.
So maybe I'll just
refer you to those pages
in the book, where you'll
spot this matrix equality.
And then next to
it is the algebra
that you have to do to check it.
I can just say, because I want
you to look to the right spot
there, maybe I'll take out
the great-- This is sometimes
called after Parseval,
or some other person.
Yeah, the algebra--
Let me start the algebra
that made this thing work.
We want the sum, when
we multiply Fourier,
F times something, we want
the sum of w^(jk), right?
That's the coefficient, that's
the entry of F. Times c_k.
Summed from k=0 to N-1.
To 1,023.
That's the y_j that
we're trying to compute.
We're computing 1,024 y's
from 1,024 c's by adding up
the Fourier series when we
multiply by F. This is F,
this is the equation y=Fc
written with subscripts.
So this is what the
matrices are doing,
and now where do I
find that 512 thing?
How do I get M into the
picture, remembering
that the w_N squared
was w_M, right?
That's what we saw.
This is the big number,
this is half of it,
so this is a little bit of
the part around the circle.
When I go twice as far
I get to the other one.
So that's the thing
that we've got to use.
Everything is going
to depend on that.
So this was w_N, of course.
This is the N by N transform.
So now comes what,
what's the key idea?
The key idea is split
into even and odd.
And then use this.
So split into the even
ones and the odd ones.
So I write this as two separate
sums, a sum for the even ones.
w_N, now, so now the even
c_k, so I'm going to multiply
by c_(2k).
These are the ones
with even, and the sum
is only going to go
from zero to M-1, right?
This is only half of the terms.
And then look on the other
half, plus the same sum
of-- But I didn't finish here.
Let me finish.
So I'm just picking
out, I'm taking,
instead of k I'm doing 2k.
So I have j times 2k here.
And now these will be
the odd ones. c_(2k+1),
and omega_N to the j(2k+1).
It's a lot to ask you.
To focus on this bit of algebra.
I hope you're going
to go away feeling,
well it's pretty darn simple.
I mean there'll be
a lot of indices,
and if I push it all the way
through there'll be a few more.
But the point is, it's
pretty darn simple.
For example, this term.
What have I got there?
Look at that term,
that's beautiful.
That's w_N squared.
What is w_N squared?
It's w_M.
So instead of w_N
squared, I'm going
to replace that
w_N squared by w_M.
And the sum goes
from zero to M-1,
and what does that represent?
That represents the
F_512 multiplication,
the half-size transform.
It goes halfway, it
operates on the even ones,
and it uses the M.
It's just perfectly,
so this is nothing but
the Fourier matrix,
the M by M Fourier matrix,
acting on the even c's.
That's what that is.
And that's why we
get these identities.
That's why we get
these identities,
because they're acting on
the even-- The top half is
the even guy.
OK, this is almost as good.
This is the odd c's.
Here I have, now
do I have w_M here?
I've got to have w_M.
Well, you can see.
It's not quite coming out right,
and that's the twiddle factor.
I have to take out a w_N to the
power j to make things good.
And when I take out
that w_N to the power j,
that's what goes in the
D, in the diagonal matrix.
Yeah.
I won't go more than that.
You couldn't, there's no
reason to do everything here
on the board when the
main point is there.
And then the point was
recursion and then, oh,
let me complete the recursion.
So I recurse down to
256, then 128, then 64.
And what do I get in the end?
What do I get altogether,
once I've got all the way down
to size two?
I have a whole lot
of these factors
down in the middle,
the part that
used to be hard is now down
to F_2 or F_1 or something.
So let's say F_1, one by
one, just the identity.
So I go all the way.
Ten steps from 1024,
512, 256, every time
I get twiddle factors.
Every time I get P's.
A lot of P's, but the F_512,
what used to be the hard part,
has gone to the easy part.
And then what do I have?
I've got just a
permutation there.
And this is the actual work.
This is the only work
left, is the matrices
like this, for different sizes.
And I have to do those.
I have to do all
those twiddle factors.
So how many matrices
are there, there?
It's the log, right?
Every time I divided by two.
So if I started at
1,024, I do ten times,
I have ten of those matrices
and have me down to N=1.
So I've got ten of these, and
each one takes 1,024 or maybe
only half of that.
Actually, only half because
this is a copy of that.
I think the final count,
and can I just put it here,
this is the great number,
is each of these took
N multiplications.
But there were only log
to the base two-- Oh, no.
Each of them took half
of N multiplications,
because the D and
the minus D are just,
I don't have to repeat.
So half N for each factor
and the number of factors
is log to the base two
of N. Ten, for 1,024.
So that's the magic of the FFT.
OK.
It's almost all on one
board, one and a half boards.
To tell you the key point,
odds and evens, recursion,
twiddle factors, getting down
to the point where you only
have twiddle factors left and
then those multiplications
are only N log N. Good?
Yes.
Right, OK.
Now, that's discrete transform.
The theory behind it and
the fantastic algorithm
that executes it.
Are you ready for a convolution?
Can we start on a topic
that's really quite nice,
and then Friday will be
the focus on convolution.
Friday will certainly
be all convolution day.
But maybe it's not a bad idea
to see now, what's the question?
Let me ask that question.
OK, convolution.
So we're into the next section
of the book, Section 4.4,
it must be.
And let me do it first
for a Fourier series.
I have convolution of series,
convolution of discrete.
Convolution of integrals,
but we haven't got there yet.
So I'll do this
one, this series.
So let me start with
a couple of series.
f(x) is the sum of
c_k*e^(ikx), say.
g(x) is the sum of some
other coefficients.
And I'm going to ask
you a simple question.
What are the Fourier
coefficients of f times g?
If I multiply those
functions, equals something.
And let me call those
coefficients, h maybe.
h_k*e^(ikx), and my question is
what are the coefficients h_k
of f times g?
That's the question that
convolution answers.
Actually, both this series
and the discrete series
are highly interesting.
Highly interesting.
So here I wrote it
for this series.
If I write it for the discrete
ones, you'll see, so let
me do it over here
for the discrete one.
Because I can write it
out for the discrete ones.
My y's are c_0 plus
c_1 e t-- No, w.
I have this nice notation, w.
plus c_(N-1)*w^(N-1), right?
That's the-- Ooh.
What's that?
I haven't got that right.
Yes, what do I want now?
I need, yep.
Sorry, I'm looking,
really I'm looking at y_j,
the j-th component of y.
So I need a w^j, w^(j(N-1).)
Yeah, OK, let me-- OK.
Alright.
And so that's my f.
I'll come back to that,
let me stay with this.
I'll stay with this to
make the main point,
and then Friday we'll
see it in a neat way
for the discrete one.
So I'm coming back
to this. f has
its Fourier series. g
has its Fourier series.
I multiply.
What happens when I
multiply this times this?
I'm not going to integrate.
I mean, when I do
this multiplication,
I'm going to get
a mass of terms.
A real lot of terms.
And I'm not going to
integrate them away.
So they're all there.
So what am I asking?
I'm asking to pick out
all the terms that have
the same exponential with them.
Like, what's h_0?
Yes, tell me what h_0 is?
If you can pick out
h_0 here, you'll
get the idea of convolution.
What's the constant
term if I multiply
this mess times this
mess, and I look
for the constant
term, h_0, where
do I get the constant terms
when I multiply that by that?
Just think about that.
Where do I get a
constant, without any k,
without an e^(ikx)?
If I multiply that by that.
Well tell me one place I get
something. c_0 times? d_0.
Good.
Is that the end of the story?
No.
If you thought that
multiplying the functions,
I just multiplied the
Fourier coefficients,
the first point is no.
There's more stuff.
Where else do I get a
constant out of this?
Just look at it, do
that multiplication
and ask yourself
where's the constant.
Another one, yep.
You were going to say
it is? c_1 times d_(-1).
Right.
Right. c_1 times d_(-1).
And tell me all of them,
now. c_2 times d_(-2).
And what about c_(-1)?
There's a c_(-1).
It multiplies d_1.
And onwards.
So the coefficient
comes from, now how
could you describe that?
I guess I'll describe it as,
I'll need a sum to multiply.
This will be the sum
of c_k times d what?
Minus k, right?
That's what you told me,
the piece at the start,
and that's the pattern
that keeps going.
OK, that's h_0, the sum
of c_k times d_(-k).
Now, we have just time
to do the next one.
We've got time but
not space, where
the heck am I going to put it?
I want to do h_k, I guess.
Or I better use a
different letter h_l,
let me use the letter h_l,
and God there's no space.
Alright, so can I-- Yes. h_l.
OK.
So this was h_0, let me keep
things sort of looking right
for the moment.
OK, now you're going to fix h_l.
So what does c_0 multiply,
if I'm looking for h_l,
I'm looking for the
coefficient of e^(ilx).
So ask yourself how do I get
e^(ilx) when that multiplies
that?
When that multiplies that, and
I'm looking for an e^(ilx),
I get one when c_0
all multiplies what?
This is it. d_l, right.
And what about for c_1?
Think of here, I
have a c_1*e^(i1x).
What does it multiply down
here to get the exponential
to be l? ilx?
It doesn't multiply d_(-1).
It multiplies, c_1
multiplies? d_(l-1).
Good, good. l-1, right. l-1,
and what are you noticing here?
c minus, I'll have
to fill that in.
But you're seeing
the pattern here?
And what was the pattern here?
Those numbers added
to this number.
And now these numbers add to l.
Those numbers add to
l, whatever it is,
the two indices
have to add to l,
so that when I multiply
the exponential they'll add
to e^(ilx).
They'll multiply to e^(ilx).
So what goes there?
It's probably l+1, right?
So that l+1 combined with
minus one gives me the l.
If you tell me what goes
there, I'm a happy person.
Let's make it h_l.
We're ready for the final
formula for convolutions.
Big star.
To find h_l, the
coefficient of e^(ilx),
when you multiply that
by that, you look at c_k,
and which d is going to show
up in the e^(ilx) term? l-k,
is that what you said?
I hope, yeah. l-k.
Right, that's it.
That's it.
So we've got a lot
of computation here.
But we've got the idea of
what, we've got a formula.
And most of all we
have the magic rule.
In convolutions,
convolutions are,
things multiply but indices add.
Things multiply,
numbers multiply,
while their indices add.
That's the key
idea of convolution
that we'll see clearly
and completely on Friday.
OK.